hello there reject nation the knights of moons
have occurred for the episode two full-length
watch-alongs you're going to talk about remove
that with us over at our patreon page master
thanks to all become superior just for checking
out the content we've got offer over there but if
you can't share support by our patreon sure
support by leaving a like that would mean a
lot subscribe click the notification bell to get
notified when our reaction for the next episode of
moon knight is up follow this man koi zhangro on
his youtube channel but especially his tick tock
post theories and news all the time on there it's
great it's the best tik tok i've ever seen also
then boys at prepper thanks for helping us edit
down these highlights tick tock tick tock let's go
i can't tell the difference between my waking life
graduate accents i must warn you what you're
about to see is going to melt your brain
area 51 like mi6 bonkers
brother yeah proof ready yeah
it's like he wants to show it off he's like
proud in his own way wait for it here it comes
no no no no wait why are you going in what
are you doing you donut just a minute oh no
any museum property on your purse no i i haven't
i haven't nicked anything that's
why i have that no nothing
oh that's why i guess the job
as a cabbie i appreciate that
that's a cool shot i like that a lot i
know you number 43 right i never forget
a face especially that handsome devil i
mean come on but i do forget an accent
i wonder if there's an easter egg if you scan
that qr oh oh maybe an easter egg all the rest of
oh whoa whoa looks like a compass i need you to
listen to me very carefully oh there he is here
he comes hello i'm gonna go lay down on that [ __
] back there gonna take a nice nap oh god are you
joking sleep i'm never gonna go to sleep again
look i don't care how bloody handsome you are
i serve can't you i'm his
avatar which means you are too
the egyptian god of the moon oh
my god that's the stupidest thing
which is a fragment of an underdone potato
i'm gonna go straight to the authorities
and they're gonna put me away so i
don't hurt anyone else and hopefully
take your key who's the
dominant body oh that was cool
all the shadows that's beautiful
look upon me he is incredible
sorry i loved it
oh
mark where have you been is this steven the latest
fake identity for you i figured that you're using
they're in love now it's not
okay yeah i'm still your wife
nice malware did you say wifi oh my are we married
she looks happy no this is my mom's flat marceline
you sent these papers but you never signed
them did i uh this is what you wanted okay
everything you told me that we needed to move
on you've been served divorce yeah are you doing
this or not i don't expect you to believe me i've
stephen listen to me honestly don't really believe
myself all i can do is try to you're making a
mistake trying to show you what i found yeah
it's kind of like the movie ghost in some ways
stop what you're doing right now all sorts of get
away from the bag don't show her what's in the
bag you're going to get her killed you hear me
now you're done i'm steven grant i work in a
gift shop and i think i'm in real danger and
i think maybe that you might be the only person
that can help me oh softy hello officers how are
you stephen graham anyone else here with you uh
here with me no um what's this it's a paperweight
where'd you get a paperweight shop
with some infinity stones around it
you're in possession of a stolen item no no i
don't i don't have it but don't no it's not here
awkward fella looks just like you fake
passport and a thief you just come with us son
you're no mama man
so who are these guys i assume
they are going to be working for
another god or ethan hawk hydra
got it okay hydro the hydra
see if he's got the merc now
why would you tell oh yeah
mark specter versus religion
is that what you think i'm
i am never giving you control again do
you hear me i hear you loud and clear
i'm curious do you think that can't you
chose you as his avatar because your mind
would be so easy to break or because it was
broken already good question yes before you
get excited put on the cape i'd love to
take this opportunity to show you around
oh people don't want to hear good news they'd
rather cling to their fear cling to their pain
reaction channel to dolphins colt reacts i was
the fist of vengeance can't you punishes those
who have already walked an evil path his
retribution comes too late by the time his
fist of vengeance arrives
people have already suffered
i get it right i wonder if this shoes is
a retribution for his time with konchi
reason isn't that a bit dodgy like trusting
the judgment of a weird crocodile lady
light the path to good by eradicating
the choice of evil which brings us
to the scarab dude she's like a pre-cog minority
reports happen though functions as a kind of
compass leading us to ahmed's tomb evil eradicated
stephen ah he is persuasive do not give layla
just give me the body give it a bite give me the
body just give me the body this is ahmed's gift
to her first avatar contains in a tiny sliver
of her power i don't want to use it men don't
where is the scarer i have it
and keep this safe
oh that is some power purple mcu purple
oh boy here we go the drag
me to hell vibe right there
oh my god i'm going to die
an evil magician's man cave
you can do this i promise kiss him
another way throw him out the window
oh
mr knight already nice
superhero landing i don't know
she said i needed a suit yeah the ceremonial armor
from conscious temple not psycho colonel sanders
where is guy this guy was oh um yes
great use of character based humor too
yeah oh neat
stay away from me
so i imagine you have to believe to see it
to a certain level maybe like it's a gift
seeing is believing ouch
they really saved a lot of this fight scene
wow that's so crazy you can't handle this yeah
i never thought the roll-up sleeves
were used comedically this is amazing
oh
ow it looks like a comic book panel
all right do it take control for now
in his eyes too
yes
oh
get to the moon
oh yeah
yes money shot
this feels like a genuinely great
90s movie yeah yeah like a good one
fun in the right ways like the
supernatural horror action movie
yeah like an instant cult classic of
those movies yeah yeah disturb man
it belongs to me i can offer you food clothing
but i am unable to offer you this thank you
i should live to see the world we make but
i've decided you're a bad guy you're judgmental
jerk he doesn't want to serve the god he wants
to become the god uh this is what it's like
being on the inside oh interesting i don't trust
anything you say you hurt people hitting him
i'm never gonna let you hurt anyone else
ever again shut up it gives you a moment
whoa
you were nothing more than a corpse when
i found you you think you owned this body
may not like my next candidate near and
dear as she is to you where are we going
where the hell do you think see ya egypt
marvel body shot let's see it
we're going to the liquor store
oscar isaac's like ah i'm in shape enough
yeah aaron and justin
so there is no opening credits other it's just
the marvel fanfare there's not like title sequence
lets the show speak for itself i think it's the
first one to do that i think that before they shot
anything they got in a room and said yeah before
we write this first episode let's make a shot
list of how many cool symbolic mirror moments
we could have let's put each amount per episode
they're like we had a spread of six we have 60
shots let's do like 10 an episode from here on
the the most frequent note was just can
we get more mirrors in here can we have
more reflective surfaces it's got more mirrors
that have more and more cracks on this one yeah
it's you know his inner turmoil
it's sternalized through the range
he himself is breaking from that crack in
his psyche in this movie i mean it's always
beautiful to look at as much as i'm making a
sarcastic little just it's always beautiful
look what a show amazing and it's always used
at the appropriate moments i love the way they
like locked off the camera when he's kicking the
pyramid there like you just get every impact of
the force of his anguish because like he's
kicking himself in a way so it's like you
get the feeling of you and the pov of being kicked
absolutely i've also definitely met ethan hawk's
character that's definitely he's doing such
a good job with that like cult leader since
what the hell are you getting at here mccoy
just said he was part of a call protagonist
yeah he's the good guy cults are good postcard
at scene credits that's my post credit scene
look at all the straight face
we had it yeah you guys immediately i
was like i can't believe i brought this
joke right now because that's the joke
we need to bring back that is the joke
commitment the co-producer son danielle iman
holding it down oh sarah haley finn is a
consulting producer on this one she's a casting
director that's interesting i'm glad they gave
her more power she's really helped shape this
universe she should get more credit said design
oh wow there were vfx in the show ah that was
all practical everyone who worked on the mirror
they're a mirror
mirror wrangler fabricator behind the scenes
you're going to see like a bunch of grips of
prop people being like we use
like 48 mirrors per episode
we actually have the actors stand to
the left of cameron we shoot into a
mirror to catch the performer that's
actually oscar isaac's face the other
way yeah the reason it looks strange
everything's flipped in the show what
i'm still going with this this credits joke
i'm i'm here you said you sound really over
it oh yeah now we're here we've got to
commit to it we haven't even gotten to the
let me see there's a post credit scene
i want to see who dubbed this in brazil
mirrorist yes good job's important yes
this is a choice this is truly a choice
it's worth the hour just play credits i'm
gonna talk about it just take credit the
credits it should be the end of all our videos
oh us watching the credits that's the reaction
encourage more people to appreciate
all the people the time and efforts
i ignore my mental health you see people say
mental health and that always sounds negative it's
like you say that's all it's like that's something
that needs to be worked on okay just mental state
is it healthy is it not healthy but physical
state is it healthy is it not wouldn't you say
your mental health does always need to be worked
on of course that's not one of those i'm saying
there's only nine times that time when someone
says mental health oh it's going to kind of
associate yeah the connotation is you need to work
on your problem right right as opposed to your
mental health should always be addressed mental
health should just be a category of like health
is it healthy you're not healthy well you know
here in america we're just learning about mental
health so obviously we're only going to talk about
it when it's a problem i don't need to worry just
looking into it my mental state is at a great
health always always at a healthy all-time high
all right guys let's review this let's all
right i like i liked the order last time
please take over my body i i'm just uh dazzled
i'm really enjoying the evolution of this show
and i appreciate it in this episode how much
they really clung to and drove home i feel like
there could have been too much of the stephen and
mark debate but i really love how throughout this
episode you have that at play as the end comes
up steven actually gets a few licks in he's kind
of feeling it he's coming around to the life that
he has been plopped into but then ultimately does
give over control to mark and it's the beginning
of what i would imagine could be some kind of
interplay that's a little more amicable between
the two or at least a little more lucid between
the two just even more of that dynamic between
him and ethan hawke from the last episode of this
episode like i really cannot say enough about just
how much i'm enjoying this thus far and two i mean
what uh crap i'm blanking on her name but you
know the the addition of of layla there you go
uh you know he reads the comments i mean honestly
expert writes the comics i didn't ask about it
i'm just gonna go on record right now like a
john episode five he's like i'm not the one
just take the body guys put me in
the reflection and i'll just be quiet
but no comic john doesn't have a mustache i
just picture like comment shots the exact same
but like mustacheless and then i got white
chaps on it that's nice that's my outfit
and a big whip uh but yeah no no i i like how
this is sort of gradually growing and you get
that pitch of fight club meets indiana jones and
you know i feel like it's getting to that but it's
taking its time it's growing gradually
it's doing that with a lot of thrilling
and tense action and stuff like that and one thing
that struck me in this episode was out of a lot of
the marvel stuff this has a better grasp on humor
circa character perspective rather than let's
pepper in a joke that someone wrote as punch up or
something like that like you said that 90s action
fantasy horror vibe where yeah it's he's a fish
out of water so of course there's gonna be some
humor that comes with that and i appreciate that
that levity is able to balance off against what
could potentially be one of the more cultish
sort of darker corners of the mcu thus far
so i think the end of days flavor really
works for this and i wouldn't have expected
that if you told me it was a 90s horror
thriller type show i've been like that's
like what you you clarified twice because for
some reason that connotation is like a demerit
but in this case it's really not like it's a
very positive thing it's like when you watch one
of those from the knives you're like that's it's
good yeah you go back to like dark city it's great
so like spawn director's cut isn't as bad as the
actual yeah but like the faculty final destination
like there's there's a great genre yeah i mean
yeah but i i think that really works with what
you're saying with the humor sensibilities is that
since moonlight is a funny character but he's not
spider-man moon knight is a funny character but
he's not shield there's different types of humor
to make these characters work and this one does
feel very authentic to not only the show but to
what i sense of the character and it doesn't feel
like it's like oh it's been dark for a while make
a joke it's this is something this character
would actually do i never would have imagined
mr knight this early nor would i have imagined mr
knight rolling up his sleeves to be for a comedic
effect because when we all saw that mr that poster
where the sleaze rolled up we were like oh badass
and then they used it comedically and it worked
really well so i i really enjoy the fact that
that costume could be the badass suit or it could
be what happened where it's like i need a suit
like it's in universe humor that's landing really
well to me so far the moments between stephen and
mark are in this episode the most accurate how
the comic felt to me but like the scenes of them
talking and interacting and fighting for control
there was a few moments where like i could almost
see the square panels not speech bubble panels but
the square panels that moon knight uses to like
keep everything going the narration panels yeah so
i felt narration panels happening in real time and
this episode maybe more than the first one felt
like a comic the sweeping shot where konchu moved
three times felt like a pop pop pop panel from a
book where it'd be like he's hearing series here
like it's it's overused it's a trope but like
a comic come to life in so many ways like it's
so pretty a living comedy a living comedy i've
been the immortal words of joel schumacher it's
very good it might it might overtake loki if it
gets sticks and landing i'm gonna say it again
what do you got for the third portion
we both have to do the slow oh okay
which is going
i'm not a fan anymore this is uh all trash
your friends directed this yeah i'm like
so proud of my crap directly i'm gonna tell
you i'm just saying crap utter crap yes suck
no this is this is some of my favorite uh so far
i love how it's not even acknowledged the mcu like
it hasn't even done any of that right which
for some people automatically means it's good
for me i think it's cool because it
really makes it its own thing like we've
talked a lot about different genres that
it's sort of implemented here throughout
i was even getting vibes of like the movie
ghost in a lot of ways you know like having
that you've seen ghosts right
we'll be using ghosts yeah
but there are elements of ghosts in
here you know i think i think with the
think about what do you mean sure
watch me i'm agree with you watch me go
all right i think there's shades of it there are
shades of like with layla and steven that kind of
remind me of like whoopi trying to communicate
with demi and then also with like stephen going
around but he's got like a ghost following
him around telling him what to do as well
has that vibe but i think also even with mr knight
they implemented like a tone and genre style that
i just didn't expect it felt something almost
akin to like a fred astaire movie in some ways
i loved how in that fight the way he is with
his kind of suit and the way he moves around
kind of like a dance out of like a 30s movie then
when he's they're fighting the jackal the both of
them the fact that they chose not to show the
jackal it was working on so many levels for me
like it was like watching the because the
suit kind of reminds me like the invisible
man for some reason and then you're watching
the invisible man fight something invisible
and then the way they're moving around fighting
it you're just watching the choreography of the
stunt work it really gets the shine word usually
if you can see the jackal yeah you're trying to
find them you're distracted by the visuals around
you and it made it work much stronger you're also
seeing it through the perspective of how everyone
else is seeing with like this weird chaos of
like this is just a crazy man right this dude
belongs in the loon bin you know i kind of vibe
about it i thought it was really strong and
the the layla relationship i i became more
interested in her when she showed up
and was ash and i really like the way
stephen grant the way stephen grant has an
affinity towards her is what was maybe lacking
in the marriage between mark spector and her yeah
you know yeah and so i liked having that extra
layer to establish with like oh maybe she might
fall in love with steven you know i've also
enjoyed that mark's like not the greatest because
like in the comic books mark spectre is kind of a
dick because moon knight can be kind of a dick
so it was nice yeah like that guy he owes me
money so i'm enjoying that we have a very likable
protagonist and an unlikable protagonist as one
protagonist because like i see the need for mark
but he's a swiss army knife so far i'm not like oh
i'm supporting mark like i don't trust mark
spectre and i like that because i'm rooting for
our more squirrely guy because of how endearing
he is whereas mark i was afraid would be more
interesting and i'd be less interested in steven
and i'm not yet they both serve a different
like narrative purpose and i was also telling
john before i really like that this show
as you said isn't connected to the mcu because
a lot of times like once the comic gets into
the hundreds people are like oh i can't jump on
it's too intimidating it's a new arc you could
show this to someone that's never seen a marvel
movie and it's an abuser you really can people
say that all the time about like every marvel
property now but this one this one you really
i've watched a few marvels with my family and
that is often a distinct barrier and this is a
show i've been sitting here going i could easily
put this on and everyone would have fine time
just like they did with loki yeah and loki's got
even way more of that sort of like oh the marvel
universe but but it's doing it in a madcap way
whereas this is just very much focused on what
it is and what it's doing yeah it's of like that
mummy returns absolutely like mommy returns more
than mommy i would say yeah yeah yeah i said at
the top before the credits even happened that like
this reminded me of justin aaron's work before
i knew this was one of their episodes because
it's half muhammad i believe his name uh and
then half justin aaron and i could tell some
of their shots but it worked so well for this
universe that it's kind of like what i wanted
a igrad's ant-man like a stylized choice in the
marvel universe this felt like one of their movies
while still working because marvel let them and
it still also feels like the first episode like
the tonalities totally play here for their
universe and i'm excited for their loki no even
more their thing that they directed before was
like uh times yeah yeah yeah they did uncut gems
yeah yeah yep you really get that kind of like
paranoia everyone was really surprised yeah angry
at each other i didn't think i'd like sandler's
computer's voice for work yeah i'm cautious
i really also it's it's just a tiny
little moment but i really love when leila
we're gonna film the third one today i can tell
sorry we're gonna do it all in the chat right now
it's all good
it was a tiny tiny tiny little thing but i really
it really struck me when layla calls him stephen
for the first time she's accepting him yeah yeah
yeah i love to that that that how hard they make
it because he doesn't understand what's happening
to him and i like that it's really hard for him to
get across what he's going through without being
like i don't i think i have a split personality
like i believe the struggle in his being like so
overwhelmed and perplexed trying to communicate
what is happening clearly you know the interplay
of like okay mark just keep making whatever weird
choice you want to make and then finally
it comes around to like okay maybe this is
more than i bargained for more than i
gave it credit for or something like that
i also really liked that i was reluctant for mark
to take over every time then at the end when mark
did it felt like the villain when winning a
little bit like when we lost steven to him
i really liked it i was like no no no no we
need the guy that's like lesson control back
we also see why we need mark and i love that
last shot in egypt that to me with him sitting
with the drink looked like mark spector like
it was cool to see like that's the comic to
me well it makes me wonder that if the third
episode is gonna dive heavily into we're gonna
do much more mark specter's perspective in egypt
and things like that you know and it's gonna be
like leaving off here i really liked that you
know he takes hold and those last final moments
do give you a sense for him as a person it
felt like a strong character introduction
so that now next time yeah we can really dive
in and learn who he is and then have two fully
formed characters in one body yeah and that's some
[ __ ] acting man we said it in the last episode
but oscar isaac every his eyes like there's so
many moments ross talk in that argue which is
all editing but still like is so good like and
i know that the people some people have problem
with the accent i love it because it distinguishes
them so completely that they're literally in the
same outfit so it'd be really distracting if they
sounded the same and you also don't want something
that's like too similar and you you have such a
dichotomy between these two characters it is two
separate performances down to the mannerisms
down like there's just so much i don't know
i think i have a minnesota accent can one
of them have a mullet i think so i agree
well i think you guys touched on two points of
what is how you talk about his perplexity and
the complexity of his situations is that is first
and foremost in scenes that often present humor
because part of a lot of the humor that came out
of this one is oh it's a fish out of water story
something that i didn't actually anticipate
even though the trailers really cleared him
the first episode did but i'm like oh wait a
minute yeah this is like the breaking act two
fun and games this is the fish out of water
tail here and even in the scene with arthur
when he's at is like little all the zealots
and stuff the humor that comes through there
does not feel like primary it doesn't feel
like who talks first do i talk first huh
star wars oscar isaac doesn't feel
like this joke come from right and
like we're going to eat the funny
right now they fly now classic oscars
how good the script is is a testament to them
getting oscar isaac back because he was like
you guys screwed me with this in
the same studio in the same thing so
i see why he signed on for this because we all
talked like i can't believe he's back to doing
franchise anything with disney and this is the
opposite they're letting him go well i think the
way that you work with the humor and i think what
they've done narratively with mark spector because
john if i'm not mistaken yeah yeah i'm listening
sorry i i need you to check you don't worry don't
worry in the moonlight comments uh-huh
yeah it's usually mark spector is the
protagonist that you're following yes that is
you are correct god yeah only your reputation
is intact i really read a sentence and i try
to retain it and the sentence was mark spectre
no what i'm saying is that what you were talking
about with mark spector of like you feel like
he's not really a good guy and they're leaning
into that they've done this cool narrative trick
where they'd switch the perspectives they switch
to the primary person as you're gonna be following
the protagonist so to speak and they're doing
that thing with the supporting character mark
spector where he is like the tough guy [ __ ] but
you know there's a good guy yeah we'll uncover him
yeah well that's covered on moonlight and he is
slowly going to be showing that's because he's
like the closed off like the wolverine british
batman ish uh kind of guy but you know he has
the quote-unquote save the cat quality about
him because he literally saves our protagonist
yeah yeah stephen's again he's like
saving our protagonists and also made
maybe do these experiences i was asking like
what will the arc of this show be and as i'm
watching this it's like okay it looks like mark
is gonna have to learn to be a bit more vulnerable
and stephen is gonna have to learn to quit
being such a a wimp in a lot of situations
you know like he's not a wimp but he's
learning to stand up for himself to fight
back do you know and i think that's what
makes you root for him so much and i do like
the idea of having one character have to go two
different directions in his own arc i like that
yeah they're gonna learn from each other yeah
and then in the third act we get a cabbie
they don't know the best of both worlds i know
what they're going to do they're going to stand in
front of a clean unbroken mirror it's just going
to be a one great big miracle not a crack in there
beautiful lighting it's going to be amazing very
excited from domestics and then layla is totally
karen allen what's her name yeah oh indiana
jones yeah yeah yeah john you're harry comics
or marrying crane marion crane that's what it is
has a rachel nice look about her which is funny
you mentioned the mummy like she's got that like
bad ass rachel i thought it was smart is that she
actually kind of looks like the person stephen
was going to take on a date with yes that was i
thought it was her first yeah yeah i like that
he's got a type even though he doesn't know a
subconscious has a type like he literally has
other side both of them like this type of well
it seems like mark here's here's what i'm getting
from the relationship mark is an [ __ ] mm-hmm
that's all i got now mark is an and it seems
like the steven personality is all derived
from the good that he sees within layla oh yeah i
mean if you're looking at like oh all the french
poems like mark you don't like that [ __ ] you
know you read this flowery crap always watching
football and and cleaning picking your butt
you know that's what you're doing all the time
that's a really good night i like the french
uh where he he's trying to form this this
positive self perhaps say hieroglyphics
the obsession with the egyptian stuff
i like that it's good note yeah i don't think
it's a note i think it's right there well excuse
me so clear things he loves and can't you it's
gonna be like on my planet i am considering you
well i think it was so cool how how uh arthur
harrow knew so much about what was going on i
loved how he was doing like a play-by-play too of
what was happening like what kanchu was probably
saying like this is all predictable you don't
need to trust him i know better but it seems
like they've really established that this guy
has no interest in serving some higher god yeah
i like him by himself for that show that's like
hey he's not in it for actually even in his mind
the selfless reasons like he wants to be the
judge although i did like it a little bit more
when he was doing it for to sort of like i like
the idea of like two gods battling it out like
systems i think i'm waiting to see how
they'll elaborate on that note because yeah
that last beat where it's clear like oh no like
there's something interesting about having him be
you know as he is presented yeah servant a leader
somebody who is compassionate for the people that
he at least has seen to be worthy and good and
blah blah but then yeah to see that moment pass
in this you know this homeless guy who didn't
deserve to be wasted you know and he didn't
even well and he doesn't even do did not weigh
him on the scales man and so yeah that's like an
overtly villainous deed you don't see the
compassion and the compassion was interesting yeah
that's the one thing that i am curious to see go
forward as i was sitting here admiring this going
wow i especially when he does the play-by-play i'm
like oh this is a nice subversion because you know
they're already at odds but to have him be like
no i know what you're going through and and i
can also make this seem even more like a psychosis
you're experiencing or something and also being a
former moon knight yeah absolutely uh i thought
that was quite compelling and you know i'm sure
that will still hold in the dynamics when he meets
with stephen and mark and all that but yeah having
that extra look behind the curtain of what the
rest of the characters don't really know yet
is yeah i'm curious to see if they'll still be
able to keep the character of arthur feeling as
rich and interesting as a villain or if he will
sort of start to slope into you know i just want
to be a god you know can't wait for midnight sons
this there's so much ghost rider that like pulls
from this kind of mythology that this because of
this you can get ghost rider to feel very natural
in the mcu as much as this is removed from the
mcu it really allows for an entire new corner
like guardians did you like conscious head on fire
you're halfway there there it is boom you're like
your skull's on fire but i'm good he's trying to
you know get that marvel r-rated supernatural door
open i mean it worked this was like let's
just not acknowledge mcu in this one yeah
i wonder if it ever will like if we get to
episode six and there's any like how balls
that's what would make it more rewarding when
he does crossover with someone yeah that because
of the fact that none of it was ever mentioned
before and in the books like whenever he's there
it's like oh shit's getting real move nights here
there's been times he's teamed up but that was all
in his head they didn't team up with anyone yeah
so is that right john you are well don't even
sweating that was the second sentence and then
moon night it wasn't advanced but it would be so
cool it would be so cool to have a character who
you never know when they'll show up in the greater
universe and when they do it does come with
that like oh dang yeah like there's a tone shift
happening right right like another presentation i
think these are two of the best outfits i've ever
seen in marvel mm-hmm the mr knight and the
moon knight i think they're both phenomenal
yeah and i love the cape and i i can see where
it's sometimes see drive it it really makes the
imagery of a cape sing and it's not easy to have
a cape like in in a in a in a universe that's
grounded they're it's a cake i mean there's shots
where it's definitely practical no yeah but it's
like running on rooftops and stuff in london you
know it's definitely cgi it's just cool to get
like the cgi it's those parts of it feel like
a little bit of american werewolf in london too
i like that yeah oh yeah yeah good call there's
a lot of things here your friends gonna watch
us i feel like we said a lot of good things hey we
like your work and they have those things i'm sure
they have plenty of time to watch i'll take one
through their good job on good time and uncut yeah
in real life watch spring in the endless dust
and hair are incredible yeah oh the
ones from the safety brothers yeah
absolutely yeah so they're going
to watch this the sci-fi 70s
just tell them to watch the review
i've said a lot of positive things just
i'll make sure they see that this part
though that you asked i can make a
uh cut down of just what i said just break we're
not even here yeah i'm gonna make sure they know
that you read this drop it on my face just begin
praising them and then work with robert pence
my own super cut of just people checking with
me to make sure the comic book references
so that i can remember this one day the rest of my
life send that to everyone in town that you're the
comic book this will be my new showdown free for
all the one day the one time roast to the occasion
all right guys all right don't show
your friends as part of the video
tell them when it gets to
24 minutes to fast forward
two times once you hit 24 minutes make
sure to fast forward a little bit yeah
we're done
another no no no we'll we'll look
very different next time you see us
i'll have a beard it's not trucking you
better now it's on sits on the ratchet
you